all right y'all are y'all ready Rob core
are y'all ready Rob core ladies and
gentlemen are y'all ready for this
greatness look here's the thing over the
course of the next six weeks we are
going to count down to the single
greatest Johnny Storm moment ever in the
history of Marvel Comics Johnny Storm's
legit here's the thing man folks sleep
on Johnny Storm but here's the crazy
thing man the end of this video is gonna
blow your ass mind because man y'all can
be screaming at me to upload the next
part once this is done so what this does
here is this initially picks up with the
main Fantastic Four team itself right
the neutral zone right kind of between
the United States Territory and that
that was claimed by the forever city of
the high evolutionary if you guys recall
the last the few videos that we did
before and this is why I say everything
that Hickman does you got to make sure
you recall it so if you guys are
unfamiliar make sure you guys check the
the link in the description it'll have
the link in the playlist you can get
caught up and so what we found out was
that at some point in time the high
evolutionary had built a city that had
what was literally an evolution engine
right an Ascension engine when this
thing powered up and it hit 100 it would
hide hyper evolve the population of the
world the inverse happened and basically
it didn't really affect the world but it
did affect the people there and the high
evolutionary basically abandoned it
right now as a result of that the city
was discovered by mole man who got the
attention of the Fantastic Four stuff
happened and then ultimately the city
Rose to the surface but with it being
the dwelling of the mole people right
mole man and the mole people it became
its own Sovereign Nation and so what
you're dealing with right now is
basically border skirmishes right as a
United States Territory versus The
Sovereign independent nation you end up
with border skirmishes that takes place
as a result of that but that is not the
main focus here that's the thing going
on in the background what we end up
doing because I know y'all looked at the
video I know y'all saw the thumbnail the
thumbnail said the return of Doctor Doom
I'm not going to leave you hanging what
we end up doing here is switching over
to Valeria right now of course Valeria
ever the Curious girl and whatever it is
ends up sneaking into the lab of Reed
Richards now one of the things to know
is that over the years in Marvel Comics
Valeria Richards intelligence had been
hinted at but it was never really a
established until you got to this run by
Jonathan Hickman for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with Valeria of
course she's the daughter of Reed and
Susan and there's a whole lot of history
there regarding the the incontinuity
theory that like Franklin Richards
controls the Marvel Universe he's the
reason nobody ages different things like
that and it's more of a fan Theory than
anything that was confirmed by Marvel
but the idea behind this is that Valeria
Reed Richards and Dr Doom are usually
considered the three smartest people in
the entirety of the Marvel Universe now
you do have Moon girl who's part of the
equation now and arguably she's up there
but the reality is that when the
Fantastic Four returned after all new
all different Marvel and Valeria
Richards showed up Marvel established
quick fast and in a hurry that lanella
is not on the same level of intelligence
as Valeria she's not as smart right so
right there like we know that Moon girl
is intelligent she's not where Valeria
is and so the result of this is that
Valeria as she goes through like the air
ducts and so on and gets to the lab of
Reed her immediate reaction is just like
this is the crappiest security ever but
the reality is that once Valeria gets
down into her father's lives she kind of
starts poking around looking at
different things and then of course one
of the Holograms kicks up that starts
talking about work logs and of course
starts feeding this information to
Valeria now for the most part she's
basically told everything that we
covered at the beginning of this the
Council of reads the idea that Reed
Richards was going through and looking
for every alternate reality that
basically had some beneficial outcome as
a result of civil war secret Invasion
the formation of the Illuminati all that
kind of stuff all that information he
had looked for again that's in the
playlist make sure you guys go check
that out but it's basically all that
stuff that she's caught up with learning
her father's research more so than that
he told Susan storm that he had taken
apart the bridge which is the device he
uses to look into alternate realities
right to see how alternate universes
function under any particular event and
once she realizes what's going on and
once she gets the full breadth of
information she does the only logical
thing that a person would do in this
situation but before we find out what
that is we jump to latviria now there's
a few things to know here when it comes
to Dr Doom one he's got his assistant
Boris who's a really cool guy Boris is
cool man you don't see a whole lot of
him but Boris is pretty awesome right
he's like the guy that Victor Von Doom
trusts implicitly right it's like what
would be tied the poor soul who decides
to mug Boris but here's the thing right
so what we end up doing here and it's
really kind of Doctor Doom flashing back
to the events of the Intelligentsia now
in Marvel Comics The intelligencia is
totally different from the way it was in
the MCU in the MCU the intelligencia is
the result of just lazy writing and
Marvel Comics the idea of the
Intelligentsia is that it's a coming
together of the world's greatest evil
minds right so like the leader Modoc all
those guys and they've pulled off some
pretty daring things and in fact they've
come close to eradicating the entirety
of the superhero community on several
occasions they're pretty dangerous man
and they're pretty capable but the idea
behind this is that at one point Doctor
Doom actually turned against the
intelligencia following that the
intelligence yeah had the idea of
effectively lobotomizing the smartest
Minds in the world or stripping them of
their intelligence Reed Richards those
different guys Bruce Banner and
including Dr Doom what this means is
that of course Doctor Doom is not
lobotomized but he's not as intelligent
as he was before and so as a result of
this and the fact that he hasn't quite
come back from that he ends up basically
telling Boris to bring that Christoph
Bernard now for those of the guys who
are unfamiliar with Christoph Bernard
he's not he doesn't have the most
significant role in this story he's
actually has a much bigger role in
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers than he does here but
Christopher nard was introduced back in
Fantastic Four 247 uh during John Burns
run right he was created and drawn by
John Byrne because John Byrne was
handling the entirety of Fantastic Four
at the time the idea behind Christopher
nard is that Doctor Doom had actually
taken him under his wing and because he
saw him as essentially a surrogate son
that he actually ended up putting
Kristoff Renard in a position to where
he would eventually become the heir of
lot Viria that's the reason why Kristoff
Bernard is being recalled here there was
some stuff that went on in between
Kristoff was exiled he's being brought
back that kind of thing but in the midst
of this conversation Valeria Richards
teleport words to Doctor Doom now
remember the message that was given to
Valeria when Franklin Richards from the
future came back to the past he told her
all hope lies with doom the significance
of this is that when Dr Doom's like okay
what's going on here notice he doesn't
immediately have her arrested or
anything like that and the reason why
and one of the things that Hickman kind
of hits on here but it's not overly
stated is that Dr Doom knows exactly how
smart Valeria is and he respects her for
her intelligence now there is also
history between the two and in fact
Doctor Doom is well versed with how
capable she is and it's one of those
things where Reed and Susan simply just
don't know because again Valeria doesn't
tell them because she calculated in her
brain what The Logical conclusion would
be and that it would actually have a
negative effect on the family if she
revealed her intelligence to everybody
so because of that Dr Doom is one of the
only people who knows again Pikmin kind
of building on that here but Dr Doom
respects the intelligence of Valeria and
he respects Valeria herself now those
are the guys who are aware of Doctor
Doom it takes a lot to get that guy's
respect right like to be in a position
where Dr Dooms hey man you know what I
like you it takes a lot to get to that
point it's very rare that you see Dr
Doom who's like you know what I'd like
to cut of your jib and ultimately
decides that he wants to be your friend
if Dr Doom under any normal circumstance
comes to you and says hey you know what
let's be friends he's probably gonna
destroy you because he doesn't like you
right that kind of a thing so it's one
of those really really cool moments
where you see this sort of camaraderie
now for those of you guys who did follow
our videos on Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers run this
moment right here is one of the moments
that really has a great sort of
involvement in that story where Valeria
plays a pretty significant role she's
the one that figures out there's no way
to end the multiversal collapse that's
why she tells Reed uh that you can't win
it's time to figure out how not to lose
there's a big difference there that sort
of thing but of course she basically
tells him what was going on right that
ultimately Reed Richards created a
device or even a weapon if you want to
call it that he was supposed to
dismantle it he didn't and so when Dr
Doom asks what did you do when you found
this this bit of a discovery that she
says I asked myself what would Uncle
Doom do and what Valeria did is she
turned on the bridge and entered the
portal now remember what awaits on the
other side are the mad celestials and
what's left of the Council of reeds
because remember when Reed went through
that portal and he met the Council of
reads one of those versions of Reed Drew
the attention of a crazed group of
celestials from an alternate reality who
basically started killing every version
of Reed in the council that they could
find so when Valeria gets here she
basically finds those lobotomized
versions of Doctor Doom that the council
was keeping below the Citadel but she
also finds the remnants of those members
of the council who were killed by The
Mad celestials the crazy thing here is
that the war has been going on this
entire time the whole time that like all
like ever since we ended that story and
we went on throughout the rest of the
Fantastic Four that war has still been
happening those guys have still been
fighting off those mad celestials using
a combination of their own powers
traveling to other realities grabbing
different arms and Armament all that
kind of stuff but when this bridge is
open and when these guys get there
basically the council ends up following
Valeria because once the bridge Bridge
was closed there was no conceivable
means of Escape right so it was
literally the last stand at the Alamo
but Valeria is now their way out along
the way there are a few members who are
destroyed by the mad celestials and what
this means is there are only four reads
left now one of the things that I want
to establish here is we will follow
their stories we will find out what
happens with these different versions of
Reed and each one of them are going to
have a significant role to play over the
course of this story so we're not going
to forget about them but ultimately once
they get back to Reed's uh to I guess
the main Marvel universe is Reed's lab
the portals reopen and they end up
taking off to different places around
the world and so once we jump back to
Valeria's conversation with Dr Doom that
basically Valeria is just like my father
made the wrong choice he had the option
to basically fix everything across the
Multiverse and instead he chose familial
relations he chose you and he chose me
now here's a very important distinction
to understand here here's a really
really important thing there is a theory
that's never been confirmed by Marvel
Comics that in Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers is the new Avengers run the
character Black Swan is an alternate
reality version of Valeria again it's
never been confirmed not that I'm aware
of but the idea that that version of
Black Swan could be that cold-hearted
she could be that disconnected from her
emotions and she could really just be
like I destroy whole worlds because it's
the only way to save the Multiverse
especially her connection to Dr Doom and
that Dr Doom had formed the black swans
in the first place that all this hints
at the fact that this is really why and
how it is that Valeria can be the way
that she is she's more practical than
she is emotional and in that response
that's why she says it was stupid of my
father to walk away from saving
everything and to focus on his family
instead it's such a selfish thing to do
it's like having the cure for cancer in
your hand and throwing it away because
the wide scale implementation of that
cure would take you away from your
family seemingly for the rest of your
life right and your family is more
important than saving the world right
depending on who you're talking to one
of those decisions is better than the
other which one depends on the person
but at the end the day when when she
asked this question you know like you
know why would somebody make such a
selfish decision like that the response
of Doctor Doom is like I'm not the right
person to ask but why did you come here
and she simply says all hope lies in
Doom she's doing what she thinks the
right thing is to do and when Doom's
like what are you talking about she's
like I came here because my father is
going to need your help somewhere along
the line he's going to need you right
he's going to need your Aid and when
when his his question is like why in the
world would I want to help read Richards
the response of valyria is okay so like
when I got here I honestly had no real
clue why it is that you would want to
help my dad and honestly I still don't
necessarily know but while I've been
telling you all this she says I've been
watching you closely and what I notice
is that something's not quite right
delayed people response your breathing
is slightly erratic and there's a slight
Twitch in your right hand you've
recently suffered brain damage haven't
you she immediately picks up on the fact
that Dr Doom's mental capacity has been
reduced and so when he answers her
truthfully and says yes that's correct
which again is another instance of the
amount of respect Doctor Doom has for
Valeria then she's like then that's it
you helped my father when he needs you
and I will find a way to restore your
intelligence back to the way it was
before do we have a deal and the
response of Doom is yes we have a deal
and so once the whole thing with like
the neutral zone and the border
skirmishes and all that end when Reed
gets back to the Baxter building he asks
Valeria like no how was your day did
anything go on she's like no no it
wasn't a huge deal it wasn't anything
that I couldn't handle now for the
ending here's the thing man this is this
is why I said it's gonna blow your mind
remember the body of Galactus from the
future that was brought to the Past
remember that it was turned into like a
time traveling machine and it was
brought here and then just it died when
it was being used like you remember that
like the body was just totally
incinerated the body was buried by Reed
Richards and it's it's a fair thing it's
it's a reasonable thing to do to bury a
dead body here's the problem with that
out in space is a guy who surfs the
space ways the Silver Surfer my friend
and a kind of hug something told him he
needed to come to Earth something that
he couldn't quite describe the issue is
that when he got here he realized what
it was that was pulling him here a need
to know a desire when Silver Surfer gets
to Earth Silver Surfer finds this dead
body of Galactus and let me tell you
something man he's gonna go and form the
big dude himself and when Galactus gets
here when he gets to Earth it's gonna
pop off with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace